the fight over toilet paper I just want
one incident one of several at
Australian supermarkets is desperation
for toilet paper like just going to the
bathroom
they've did you know just the the the
proper way to to wash yourself there was
when I was in Bosnia there was a Serbian
doctor who was talking about because
there is rectal cancer and other harms
that because people not washing
themselves properly down yes there right
after you they use the bathroom number
two specifically in this case but we've
been talking how to do that right you
won't believe there is a life professor
and Minneapolis area Minnesota he went
to Malaysia as a missionary first he
lived with a Muslim family and he
according to him and I met him several
times he will go to the bathroom and he
will find a pot with water and he didn't
know what did that for but he really
never get a chance to ask the Muslim
family about it why they have the pot in
the bathroom with the water yeah yeah
and then he moved from their place and
lived with a Buddhist and he found that
they don't have that part in their
bathroom yeah so he asked him how come
you don't have a pot so they start
making fun of the Muslims and ridiculing
the foot slips because they wash
themselves with the water so now we look
at it and he said Islam goes to that
much of details even how to go to the
bathroom and to clean yourself yeah now
he's masha'Allah
I'm Muslim ish or he accepted Islam yes
and then also the the they did some
tests were they with the UV lighting
they were testing people I heard this
that will do no this is specifically for
people when you go to the urinals and
you stand up in your net oh yeah and now
you can only see with this special UV
lighting but what they saw was because
of the backsplash from the urine people
are pretty much walking with urine all
over themselves but we have obviously in
Islam we have the when you go to the not
just number two but also when you go to
urinate Muslims this fall in the Sunnah
of the last prime final message said the
mankind of Prophet Muhammad you would
sit so this avoids you walking around
with urine on yourself and dung between
years not only that recently yeah
another professor he was tricking the
image of human beings and most of the
one that he have checked it seems that
they are settling and peaceful and then
one time he did the same imaging of a
Muslim and he found that he isn't quite
tranquility and peace with himself and
he found out the reason was for doing
what washing yourself and when he did
will do to non-muslims their image
changed and they have peace and
tranquility this is the evolution of
ablution for praying yeah yes yes so
allah subhanaw taala me this statement
this quran will always lead to the best
this means regardless what time and what
era you are what knowledge you have
there is going to be something even
better that this quran will tell you as
time goes on as a matter of fact there
is a professor and i think she is in
germany see is a sort of Orientalist and
she said whoever says the quran is not
fit for all times they need their head
to be exempt and god is showing the
world today how
if you follow the hygienic procedures of
the Muslims you can save yourself from a
deadly disease which is simply if you go
anywhere they say wash your hands with
water and soap
inhale water drink water make sure that
your mouth is moist and if you touch
anything make sure that you clean
yourself yeah so we're just talking
about the purity because that's that's a
part of faith demand is purity of
cleanliness and how and we're just
giving some examples that's just amazing
just from those examples there there's
so much good because I mean we see what
happens when people were in the Dark
Ages at one point right and they were
not taking baths for four months just
putting perfume or cologne over and you
had sickness and disease and whatnot but
at that time you had Muslims who are
following the example of Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessing top and all
the prophets and messengers and they
were implementing this because this
comes from the divine yes yeah he knows
better than anybody else exactly and
this is for everybody this is not
exclusive just for us this is for the
person watching this is for everybody
this way of life is for everybody
absolutely can all get enough toilet
paper if we all calm down a little bit